headed down to Hollywood on this tour
bus with my man
Duane dog Chapman I love the way you
roll thank you sir this is rollin here
isn't it yeah it is
all right ladies if you got 20 bucks
I'll talk to you
who's your favorite personality in all
of Hollywood
he calls it dog walking a chance to get
out and meet his fans the bus it's just
to promote his new show and while he's
loving taking selfies with well-wishers
it's clear late wife Beth Chapman isn't
far from his thoughts I am so lonely I
walked in the closet that smelled like
her i sat there still in my dreams is
when I see her and I'm with her you
still have on your wedding ring never
did I know what she put it on my finger
what it would mean to me Beth passed
away just over two months ago after a
long battle with throat cancer that
spread to her lungs from the wig she had
to wear to her chemo treatments it's all
documented on the couple's new series
dogs most wanted battling cancer on the
show I would stand back and watch behind
the camera when the cameras pointed
thinking dear God I would not do this if
I'm gonna die I'm gonna die in my boots
and while he misses Beth dog told us
he's not ruling out dating again someday
I walked by all these girls and dogs got
a new girlfriend not yet I don't I'm not
I'm saying I'm not gonna have one cuz I
will I'm not gonna get married as I told
you ever did you in better talk about
that oh yeah well yes because both of us
did I told one the other day that I was
kind of looking at and I said listen to
me
it'll never be another bise's dog so
we're gonna see you're gonna keep giving
them google eyes you'd better know that
right now mmm she stopped because
there's not but you know like I said
whoever I'm dating now I'm gonna make
him famous so here they come
[Applause]
[Music]